in my entire life from the very
beginning days was how do I do more for
others than anyone else on earth the
more value that you provide the more
money you're gonna make the faster you
provide value the faster you're going to
make money you want to make more money
get serious about tomorrow value that
day ask how you can add more value into
the day rise and shine it's an spresso
time good morning believe nation it
seven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have an
amazing gift inside you that I want to
see exploded onto the world so grab your
coffee and sip on today's message be
obsessed with adding value over to you
Tony Robbins when you went off what do
you think were the keys to success those
first few years by yourself obsession
without any more value than anybody else
ever dreamed of I mean my entire life
from the very beginning days was how do
I do more for others than anyone else on
earth how do I give them experiences
that are lasting how do I create change
for change was impossible how do I take
somebody from the therapy for seven
years in an hour produced that result
and the way I did that was by
challenging traditional psychologists
and psychiatrists and getting on
national radio and saying giving you
were stationed on handle in an hour
which was pretty abrasive you know as a
young kid you can get by with that stuff
but the best part was I backed it up and
so one of the first interventions I did
was in Vancouver British Columbia Canada
on the radio and this psychiatrist got
on the phone and just on the radio why
I'm just passionate you're a liar you're
a charlatan people like you should not
be allowed on the radio and I said sir I
said I said are you you know scientists
used to the course of a physician I said
well a scientist would never make it
sumption I said you've never met me
right now everybody quiet snow you call
me a liar on national radio I said she
must be stating your hypothesis
hypothesis is that I'm a liar miserable
again and if you're standing up offices
and you're truly a scientist you gotta
be willing to test it am i right yeah
yeah it's great not doing a free guest
event the Holiday Inn tomorrow night
anyone hearing my voice income I'm gonna
do a series of demonstrations and I'm
gonna take one of your clients and turn
around I said share with me somebody
that you've never been able to change I
said I'm sure you got plenty of those
you wanna play hardball because we don't
want impatience an army to change you
and I said I haven't found any course
I've done three therapies total but I
had silver fleas a long story short he
told me this one we've been working on
for seven years
it's what a snake phobia a phobia is not
just a fear it's a bunny control
response to fear so like she dreamed the
snake would bite her on the face and
then the adrenaline shoot through her
body and wake her up and there's enough
in four to seven times a night seven
years so you know he was put in the
corner and so he brought her down it
took me about 15 minutes at the end of
it I tested first and she's screaming
and shaking and then I wrapped the snake
around her and that changed my entire
career because in that moment everything
there was no question everybody honey
Thunder this woman is transformed I said
you've been treated but that's like I
just how many years then I took on
sports stars so that I can't turn around
you know I did some work with Mother
Teresa Nelson Mandela the most important
rule about business and making money is
that you need to provide value the more
value that you provide the more money
you're gonna make the faster you provide
value the faster you're going to make
money always look in every single job
that you're doing how can you not just
do the job that you are being paid for
but go over and above that's how you
start to win I look at one of the very
first brand deals that I ever got from
my business was with the
telecommunications company here in
Canada and they asked me to come and
cover this event and they paid me 500
bucks and I want me to write for their
blog and they hired me and they hired
none other people and I wrote for their
blog and it was 500 bucks they wanted
three to 500 words and that was it and I
wrote 1,500 word
and I promoted it to my audience and I
was really active in the community on
their blog and I just provided so much
incredible value which every single post
they were paying me five hundred dollars
but I was providing them with way more
value and then guess what happened at
the end of the trial when the number of
months came up where they're evaluating
between me and nine of the people who
are they're gonna go with when everybody
else is making three to five hundred
words and I'm doing fifteen hundred and
promoted to my newsletter and being
responsive in the comments and making a
video on top of it guess what they
picked me big surprise and then with
time I increased my price and went from
five hundred to a thousand to fifteen
hundred to two thousand kept increase in
a price as I kept bringing more value to
them and so I think it's so important I
think people just get locked into doing
the job that they were hired to do that
is not enough in business you never want
to just do the job that you were hired
to do you say well look I did a good job
awesome but you need to provide more if
you want to make more money you want to
get more referrals you want bigger
contracts bigger deals better clients
you need to provide more value now I
have a special bonus clip video for you
guys I think you're going to enjoy but
before that my challenge for you my
question the day is how can you double
the value that you are currently
bringing to your customers what are you
gonna do immediately to double the value
without getting paid for it yet the
payment will come what can you do to
double the value that you provide your
clients leave it down the comments below
I look forward to hearing from you thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love enjoy the bonus and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot events press out
[Music]
life should be incredibly valuable to
you if you really value your days like
that day becomes valuable so because
your day is valuable you get stuff done
you know why a lot of people end up
feeling really broke is because they're
not valuing their day they're broke
because they added no value to their day
they were reading celebrity gossip
magazines they were screwing around
online they were doing nothing that
actually moved the needle in terms of
their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow value that day ask how
you can add more value into the day
really work the day and as you do that
over and over and over again you ask how
can I serve how can I contribute how can
I take it to the next level
you do that long enough the breakthrough
happens the magic happens and the money
takes care of itself
when somebody comes and says John I want
to be a leader I was asking the question
why why do you want to be a leader I
mean do you want to be a leader because
you want a corner office do you want to
be a leader because you like to be in
control you like to want to be a leader
because you love to be in the front of
the pack you want to be a leader because
you want to have a good parking place
what do you want to be a leader because
leadership is an easy leadership a lot
of times isn't fun
leadership a lot of times its kind of
lonely there's only one reason to be a
leader and that is to add value to
people and you and I will only add value
to people if we truly value them I have
a nonprofit organization equipped this
trained almost two million leaders
internationally around the world and I
kid you not as I go to developing
countries twice a year and I travel
internationally and I sit down sometimes
I had the privilege of in in the office
as a presidents of countries and as I
watch these two developing countries the
thing that is the cardinal sin among
leadership so much is that they have
leaders of their countries that truly
don't value the people and if you and I
don't value people we will devalue
people number two if you want to add
value to people
you have to make yourself more valuable
you just have to get better you have to
keep growing you have to keep learning
you have to keep developing why very
simply if you're leading the pack you've
got to be able to give what you have and
you can't give what you don't have and
so therefore you've got to put a lot of
good stuff in so that you can pass it on
to others and share with them and and
add value to them thirdly if you want to
add value to people you have to know and
relate to what other people value you
and I have to walk slowly through the
crowd we have to listen we have to care
you see great leaders are first of all
listeners and then they're learners and
then they're leaders
they really do take their cue from the
people they understand that the key of
leadership is connecting with the people
that you lead and the only way that you
and I ever connect is by caring enough
to listen
number four is very important to me when
I'm speaking in the business community I
always share with them that for them
there are three ways to add value to
people but for me there are four and I
tell them I'll give them the three and
then there and so I'll I'll spend maybe
an hour doing those three things I just
shared with you talking about how to add
value to people and inevitably when I'm
done with the three somebody raise their
hands say John you said there for you
there was four but you said there's only
three for us I said yes it's nothing
personal but it this is about my faith
and so I don't really need to share this
with you it's because I'm trying to help
you and I I don't want to cross
boundaries with you and then for
everybody they'll say but John tell us
what yours is and I'll say well okay you
can hear mine but don't write it down
in fact don't listen because number four
for me is if I really want to add value
to people I have to do the things the
god found the most important word ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
up or that would be like a little beacon
they believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details